we've all had our lives disrupted in
ways we never expected and this pandemic
has made us consider more deeply many
things in our lives we used to take for
granted the comfort of hugging your
friends the joy of dinner out in a
restaurant and the steady supply of an
abundance of food those who work the
land plant the crops harvest the fields
raise the animals catch the fish they
keep the world fed and we're accustomed
to getting what we want when we want it
we always assume the food producers will
be there and that shelves will be
stocked with food from all over the
world this pandemic has exposed the
vulnerabilities of our food supply chain
what happens when workers get sick and
when processing plants close down when
migrant workers no longer show up david
akin looks at the impact
[Music]
southern Alberta cattle country to me
there's not a prettier place in the
world we're right on the edge of the
foothills Bob Lowe and his family have
been on these grasslands for more than a
hundred years
I guess cattle are kind of in in my
blood both sides of the family have been
in the cattle business since before the
turn of the century
but times have rarely been as tough Lowe
and other beef cattle ranchers are
running out of room on their farms the
problem the handful of meatpacking
facilities that process the country's
beef are running well under capacity as
those plants struggle to keep their
workforces free of Cova 19 yep no that's
that's the bottleneck the Cargill plant
just up the road from Lowe's Ranch has
been the most high-profile processor to
run into trouble but there's similar
issues for beef ranchers hog farmers and
poultry growers all across the country
animals that should have been shipped to
market weeks ago continue to grow and
continue to cost thousands of dollars
every day to feed low made it through
the BSE or Mad Cow crisis of the early
2000s but this crisis is one for the
ages I think mentally it's probably
worse after Mad Cow hit 27,000 beef
farmers packed it in and five million
acres of grassland pasture disappeared
soul to developers are put to other uses
and that crisis was a relatively simple
one to fix Canada just had to get its
beef back to foreign markets this thing
it's global in nature for one thing so
you know half of our production goes out
of country but this is affecting those
those other countries too so what that's
going to do in the end we don't really
know I mean we've got demand for our
product is there can it get there
we have no idea
[Music]
on the other side of the country in the
out port of Babel is just south of st.
John's Jason Sullivan readies his
Atlantic outlaw for the crab fishery
that's about to open I fish and crab
about I guess after nine like since I'm
a kid but you know full-time at last 20
years
those who farm the sea are also facing
stiff economic headwinds the Atlantic
outlaw can hold 30,000 pounds of crab
that would have fetched as much as six
bucks a pound before the pandemic the
crab is a high-end product sold to
casinos cruise ships restaurants markets
that have all crashed now Sullivan might
get three bucks a pound then you got
your bait toss which is set to fifty a
pound which is so the price of bait as
nearly as much as we're getting fur for
the crab or catch and then there's the
cost of fuel food mortgage on the boat
for some fishermen it might not even pay
to put their boats in the water this
year and meanwhile there's the challenge
of keeping fishing crews safe from Kovan
19 sleeping quarters for eight hour
below decks and it's mighty snug
certainly not the ritz-carlton and the
galley for Sullivan's crew well it's a
tight squeeze if everyone's at the table
at once just a little camper really
health authorities have issued some
guidelines for fishermen well it's not
even practical even to have these rules
for us you know they don't work it's
just impossible to do what the distance
on a boat Sullivan says other
suggestions were absurd and it was kind
of embarrassing by to be honest with you
I mean like don't share the same
toothbrush and stuff like that I mean oh
my god I mean you know we are living in
Rohr on Oklahoma you know we might have
rock Lords but we didn't need the bushes
we don't we don't we don't share the
same two brushes or anything in general
so I don't know why you know but that's
the kind of stuff that they came out
with
[Music]
back on land at the country's vegetable
and fruit farms the safety challenge is
a bit more manageable masks gloves and
sanitization
but these farmers have a different
problem a labor shortage Nick deGirolamo
and his family have been growing veggies
and herbs since the early 1960s it's
it's a life ok you've done this your
whole life like I'm you my brother and I
am I and my son and my dad still in 95
he's still on the property and we we
work seven days a week okay even
Christmas Day I show up here but during
planting season that's right now and
during harvesting dieter all moines his
family cannot do it all themselves they
bring in highly trained workers from
Mexico we need them that's all there is
good we can't not get Canadians to do
the work on a continuous basis normally
more than 25,000 temporary foreign
workers help Canada's farmers every year
most come from Mexico but also from
Caribbean and other Latin American
countries they do jobs that Canadians
will not do or cannot do everybody says
you're getting unskilled labor but
they're not unskilled labor because
they've been coming here and doing the
same jobs for years okay and coming back
to the same farms and they know how to
pick an apple and help treat you gently
if you know how to pick a berry without
squeezing it you know how to pick a
tomato without sticking their
fingernails in this is Ishmael's eighth
year working for Nick decide what person
good boss it's a good good friend but
this year several thousand of those
vital agricultural workers just are not
coming to Canada because of the pandemic
and those that did come had to be
quarantined for 14 days at the expense
of their employers the shortage of
agricultural workers and their delay in
getting to Canada means that some crops
simply did not get planted I think
there's going to be a shortage of fresh
fruits and vegetables in the fog
[Music]
meanwhile back at the ranch
Pablo tries to put it all in perspective
a little note to our customers to people
that go to the grocery store and buy our
product it's perfectly safe we've got a
problem getting it to you but that'll be
fixed and and don't lose faith in the in
food chain it's still there it just
needs a little bit of fixing